pas la peine de compter le nombre de
kilomètres ici les courses sont
interdites tout se fait en marchant dans
un tout petit périmètre entre deux
équipes de 5 ou de 6 le ballon à hauteur
de de tête on 80 dans cesau là pas de
TAAC interdit les taaces sont interdits
donc il y a des coups francs si on court
il y a coup franc si ça peut arriver
qu'il y a des fautes il coup Fran aussi
au bout de en match officiel c'est au
bout de trois fautes on a un carton bleu
on sort 2 minutes comme son cousin du
football à 11 le foot en marchant vient
d'Angleterre où il a été créé en 2011 il
faut toujours bouger avoir une bonne
vision du jeu et maîtriser sa technique
les sensations c'est bah déjà ne
serait-ce que se retrouver dans une
paire de de chaussures de foot déjà
c'estette bonne sensation qu'on avait
perdu moi ça faisait 13 ans que j'avais
arrêté le ballon après il y a les
sensations musculaires qu'on avait
oublié aussi et puis bah après je vous
dis il y a voilà il y a le le fait de de
jouer au ballon de partager parce queà
la base c'est quand même voilà voilà le
but premier c'est de venir partager de
s'amuser le foot en marchant est une
discipline mixte présenté comme étant
multigénérationnel les joueurs ont tout
de même souvent les mêmes profils
d'anciens footballeurs qui se remettent
à leur sport de
prédilection je jouis en vétéran
jusqu'en l'année 2000 j'ai eu une
fracture du du tibia peronnais j'ai
arrêté pendant une vingtaine d'années et
ça me manquait et c'est principalement
pour avoir une activité physique et puis
on se dépense quand même pas mal aux
entraînements et au match lorsqu'il y a
des compétitions arrête de tirer sur lui
maintenant on arrive à un âge où moi
j'ai 67 ans j'ai plus du tout la
rapidité que je pouvais avoir quand
j'avais 25 ans quoi laasa Marboué est la
croix d'honneur de châteauun ont créé
l'an dernier leur section les clubs
compent une dizaine de licenciés preuve
de l'attrait pour cette discipline
adaptée au sport santéux là je sais
qu'il y avait des clubs sur de personnes
atteintes du diabète ou ou ou avec des
de l'arthrose et cetera donc moi je
trouve super intéressant ce genre de
pratique parce que ça nous permet de de
de de d'avoir une dépense physique et et
tout en douceur en fait finalement
l'aspect sport santé n'empêche pas la
compétition la Coupe du Monde masculine
des plus de 60 ans s'est déroulé l'été
dernier en Angleterre l'équipe de France
et Christophe Poirier s'est incliné en
final face au pays hautes